a lot of people were raised with the
0.700 and 2011 super bowl teams where we
could consistently
apply pressure with four all right and
and that is the goal i mean that's
that's what you want
but you can't manufacture it and again
you can't overpay for it what it really
comes down to is it's not about who gets
the tax it's about how many stocks you
actually get and really how much
pressure you apply
that's what it's about
dave get him in giants gm it's about
having guys who can create the sax i
don't know what the hell he's talking
about he's trying to keep using words
until he feels good about his strategy
whatever it may be for stalking his
defensive line but when they did win a
pair of super bowls and he was there
working in the front office they did it
because they had two things they had a
great pass rush and they had a very good
offensive line that worked well together
and stayed healthy and it's almost like
i mean at least they're paying attention
to the urgency to have that because i
feel like since they won their last
super bowl they've just kind of
forgotten that those are the key
ingredients and yeah every once in a
while you'll see them try to improve but
they don't have that consistency and
they're not building i think this is
something that you craft through the
draft not through free agency but you
have to have a sustained period of time
where you are hitting on your draft
picks who play guard tackle center
defensive end defensive tackle big cat
you're absolutely right you build from
from within there and you know outside
or no inside out is how you build the
team and uh
missing on any draft picks just kills it
can kill you know the future of a
franchise when you when you have these
spots you see you look around it's a
very hard thing to do but when you have
these spots where you have a draft class
where you know multiple guys didn't pan
out that sets you back that's hard to
recover from when you're trying to build
something long-term with the cap and you
know talented players along both lines
and you know it's a combination of
not hitting on your draft picks not
developing your draft picks when you're
throwing a coach overboard every other
year
maybe you're not going to develop those
draft picks the way they could be
developed that's why it's important to
have continuity and consistency and i
feel like the giants have been
just kind of caught in this
we don't really know quite what to do
they held on to tom coughlin maybe for
too long then they got rid of ben mcadoo
too quickly even though you know they
shouldn't have hired him in the first
place and then they move on from pat
shurmur too quickly even though they
shouldn't have hired him in the first
place and i feel like a couple of years
from now we're going to be saying they
got rid of joe judge too quickly even
though they shouldn't hire him in the
first place and i think that's a problem
as well when you don't have a coach who
puts a staff in place that can get these
guys who maybe elsewhere would become
pro bowlers with you you're not getting
them to their full degree because your
program is just toxic from top to bottom
yes yes absolutely and it's um i you
know it's i feel like there's a
crossroad for a bunch of teams in this
draft and the giants definitely are one
of them especially once you answer that
question like here is our guy that we're
going to be committing to in terms of
the quarterback position here's daniel
jones now you can go because because
wouldn't you say mike like a team like
the bengals like they're not in a
crossroads they know they need a
quarterback they're going to draft you
know joe burrow a team like the dolphins
they know they need a quarterback
they're going to draft justin herbert or
tua it's the teams that have quote
unquote their guy and have to figure out
one
is this really going to be the guy going
forward and how do we maximize this guy
because you've seen it time and time
again a lot of teams are saying we need
to get a guy as a quarterback who's on
that first you know uh five-year deal
where he's a little bit cheaper than
he'll be in the latter part of his
career and try to build around that when
we have that window and trying to fit
that window what the giants are in right
now daniel jones is the guy and he is
their franchise quarterback it's going
to be up to these next three years to
try to build
a entire roster around daniel jones
before you might you know which is a
good problem to have pay him a lot of
money because he's a great quarterback
yeah and that's why when dave gettleman
says we're not going to overpay for pass
rush and you know look judavian clown is
floating around out there and i know
there are concerns about his health but
why wouldn't you go ahead and overpay
now when you aren't paying daniel jones
all that much when you aren't paying
saquon barkley all that much relative to
what you're going to be paying him
before too long why not if you don't
have the guys who are already in the
building who give you the pass rush you
need
and your only option is free agency and
there's a guy out there why not pay him
a little bit more when you have the
luxury to do so
yeah yeah no you're right you're right
this is the window this is the time to
to build up on your defense uh
and hope that daniel jones is the guy so
that you can then say hey it was good
that we invested in our defense when we
can now we can flip the script if he
ends up being a great quarterback and
you want to pay it
in 2007 they had michael strahan ocu
manure fred robbins and barry cofield as
the front four justin tuck wasn't even a
starter he ended up having a great game
in super bowl 42 when the giants beat
the patriots but you need it takes time
to build that defensive line and you
need to commit the resources to it the
draft picks to it sometimes free agency
uh fred robbins was the guy that the the
giants had signed from the vikings i
mean you have to make the right moves
you put it all together and uh and you
prioritize it that's the thing
quarterback and pass rush are the two
things that i think every team should
prioritize and it's astounding to me how
how quickly we just kind of collectively
forget how important the pass rush is
and then somebody wins a super bowl with
a great pass rush and we're like oh yeah
pass rush is pretty damn important and
then everybody prioritizes it again
and this is also not to really you know
uh stick it to giants fans here but this
is where the debate about saquon barkley
comes to play because saquon barkley is
a great talent and i expect him to be a
very good running back for you know
however long running bats can kind of
stay in that in that zone which is you
know right before they're 30 years old
right but at the end of the day drafting
a running back as high as they did
it's it's just a waste of a resource and
and we had the discussion earlier this
week when you have christian mccaffrey
getting the highest paid contract for a
running back the nfl christian mccaffrey
is a fantastic player he's the only
player who was ever in the nfl history
to start his career first three years
2500 yards rushing 2500 yards receiving
but you still probably shouldn't pay him
that much money because it's a position
that you can get maybe 80 of that value
and a lot cheaper than what christian
mccaffrey is going to be going forward
barclay the second overall pick in 2018
bradley chubb was still on the board at
the time he went fifth overall to the
broncos now he tore an acl last year but
he was great as a rookie he threatened
javon curse's single season rookie sack
record and and
as to your point of staying power
when i had the roster up for the giants
in 2007 when they won super bowl 42 that
was michael strahan's final season he
walked off into the sunset i did a
double take when i saw that he had been
drafted in 1993.
you get a defensive lineman like that
now look michael strahan's an exception
but there's no running back that's going
to hang around with you from 1993 to
2007
and they burn bright and then they're
done you get a good defensive end like
that and maybe he can make it longer
than a decade and he can be one of those
pieces as every year you try to get that
that magical combination of four guys
and maybe a fifth guy off the bench who
can wreak havoc on an opposing offensive
line that's part of it and that's why
when you do have that top five pick and
this is something you need to keep in
mind this year with the fourth overall
pick you need to be thinking about those
building block players who are going to
be there for more than 10 years
yup absolutely i think we should
probably be gms now that i've talked
this out
you're selling yourself short by being
the offensive coordinator at florida
state in the in the in the video game
that you are streaming on twitch every
night to 18 000 fans and i have a
feeling it's going to keep going up and
up all right we're going to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports